هل تستطيعون العيش بالتويتر امر وارد
الحدود لذا عليكم ربما الاستعداد المنصه
قد تتعطل التطورات تتسارع في تويتر منذ
مجيء ماسك والامر اتخطى اثاره الجدل ورمي
الدعابات لا مهندسين كافيين للعمل احد
مديريه فتره كلوز دلاله بمثال في احد
الاقسام الرئيسيه للشركه هناك ثلاث
مهندسين فقط من اصل كم 75
نعم هذا صحيح لكنها عاصفه الاستقلال هي
الاخرى حضارات وهناك مكاتب اغلقت وماسك رد
اليوم بتغريده على هذه المزرعه نشر صورا
لاجتماعه مع موظفين في تويتر في المقر
الرئيسي حول سياسته المنصه الجديده ورغم
ذلك سياسيون وحكماء وسفرات تستعد للسناريو
الاسود
احتمال عدم الصمود وارد وترقد يتعطل ابي
حسب مصادر داخليه لواشنطن بوست ولهذا
الجميع مطالب بحفظ الارشيف ليس فقط تعطل
منصه هو الخطر الاستقالات والتسريح تجعلان
منصه اكثر عرضه للاختراق والاعطال بحسب
وكاله بلومبيرج ولهذا طالب البيت الابيض
ماسك
اجراءات لحمايه بيانات
على الانترنت
اخر كبير المعلومات المضلله ماسك حلا
فريقها رئيسا كان مسؤولا عن مكافحه
المعلومات الخاطئه على المنصهره هذا الامر
اجليا في البرازيل الشهر الماضي في خضم
الانتخابات الرئاسيه انتشرت مواضيع
بتغريدات حول ادله وجدتها الحكومه على
تزويلا في النظام الانتخابيه واحد
المعالجين السابقين اللي خسر الامر لبي بي
سي تجربه للجميع ستزداد سوء بسبب الافتقار
الى التوجيه
[موسيقى]
ومن امامي مقري شركه تويتر في كاليفورنيا
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حسين التواضع
حسين انت هناك منذ ساعات الصباح يعني هذه
الحاله التي تشهدها وشهدتها منذ الصباح لو
ترصد لنا المستجدات متى سيتم اعاده فتح
المقر الرئيسي لتويتر
تحيه لك يا حنين من المفروض ان يتم اعاده
فتح المقر الرئيسي الذي يظهر خلفي هنا في
سان فرانسيسكو يوم الاثنين ولكن في
الحقيقه هناك رسائل متضاربه داخل مؤسسه
تويتر البارحه الى ماسك طلبه برساله
الكترونيه كل موظف يجيد البرمجه اي كتابه
سوفت ويرز كتابه برامج بان ياتي يجتمع معه
على الساعه الثانيه ظهرا وفي الطابق
العاشر في مؤسسه التويتر او شركه تويتر
همم بالفعل حصل الاجتماع وغرد الى الناس
بصوره وهو يجتمع مع موظفين همم هناك من
يقول الان حنين بان الماسك الان بدا
يلينفه نسيمه بعد اولا همم فصل همم نصف
اعداد موظفي تويتر وتقديم استقاله حوالي
1,000 الى 1,100 موظف يوم الخميس من هؤلاء
وهذا الخطوره تكمن عدد كبير من التقنيين
ومهندسين البنيه التحتيه لفراستراكشر
الخاصه بحواسيب وخوادم همم تويتر التي
تعمل بها البعض يحذر من ان الان قد لا
تظهر المشكله للمستخدمين التويتر ما زال
يعمل لا يوجد انقطاع بخدماته ولكن مع المد
الطويله قد اولا نشهد تباطؤ في الخدمه
مشهد همم تباطؤ بتحديث همم جدول الزمني
التايم لاين
تبادلن عن مسؤول اشكرك معنا من كاليفورنيا
من امام مقر تويتر مراسل العربيه حسين